(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] You look so fabulous.
- Thanks!
- [Kelly] Yes. Green is my favorite color.
- It is? I match all the
wallpaper everywhere.
- I know. Well, green's
a favorite color of mine.
Oh, and your liner.
- I did a little fly.
- I was a little afraid of hugging you
because people don't know this,
but you know, you put makeup on your face
and then your hands look really white.
So, they put makeup on your hands.
And I was like, "Oh, you're
wearing a white shirt."
- Oh, don't worry.
- [Kelly] I was like,
- I was already backstage taking it out
with a makeup remover
because when I put it on,
- [Kelly] Yeah
- White, makeup, it doesn't really,
it's not its best friend.
- So, how nice is it though
that your show inspires someone like Eden?
And I, and that's just one story.
You know, there's like
a plethora of stories
that are inspired by your show.
- [Lily] So cool.
- Yeah
- I love that people are
getting inspired to try new places,
get up and switch careers and like,
go find themselves in a whole new place.
I think it's wonderful.
It's so inspiring.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's like a movie.
Yours is like a show,
- [Lily] It's like a movie.
- But her life is like a real show.
It's like crazy.
And you're both from England.
- Yes.
- So is it true that
like, when you were a kid,
you had to like really
practice to lose your accent?
- It is true.
- [Kelly] And why? It's so cool.
You could have been like the
Harry Potter of the school.
- Believe me, I was
obsessed with Harry Potter.
I wish I was the Harry
Potter of the school.
- [Kelly] Okay. I'm just saying,
it could have been really cool.
- [Lily] Yeah. Everyone made fun of me
cause you're such a formidable age
at the age of like five
or six when they're like,
"Wait, you can't say your Rs"?
- [Kelly] Why are you different?
And so I used to watch
movies to replicate accents.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I used to watch Peter
Pan over and over again
and just stand in front
of the mirror and go,
"Peter Pan, Peter Pan".
And I'd try to say my Rs
to the point where it just stuck
and now I sound like this.
- I love that every person,
especially from Europe or England,
every time they say like, "water"
it sounds like, it's like the most over,
cause like we say water
and it sounds normal to us.
But every time somebody tries to do water,
it's all the Rs.
It's my favorite thing.
- [Lily] Yeah. It's all about
- It's always like
a real definitive R.
It's like we're pirates.
I love it.
Your dad of course is Phil Collins,
which is incredible to
us and normal for you.
But it's just a really
cool thing for a musician.
But what was your first concert?
Like other than obviously your dad's.
- The first concert was NSYNC.
- Oh my God.
Did he get you, like, did he hook you up?
- [Lily] I, it was,
it was a hook up,
but it was really like,
I just,
- [Kelly] It's a hookup!
You're in a picture with them.
Wait, I just saw the picture.
- [Lily] Also, by the
way, loved my outfit.
Like also the butterfly clip.
I just, I loved all their outfits.
I, I just everything about it.
- They were babies.
That's like one of their
first tours, maybe.
- You know, what was even crazier?
You know who opened for them
that no one knew who she was?
Britney Spears.
- [Kelly] What?
Your dad totally hooked you up.
- Honestly, he hooked,
he hooked up the opening act too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I remember sitting in the audience
and they were like, oh and please welcome
the opening act Britney Spears.
And everyone's like, who's, what?
Who's Britney Spears?
And she came on and did
"Hit Me Baby One More Time"
And everyone's like, well, she's good.
This is, she's good.
- [Kelly] She's gonna make it.
- She's gonna make it
- [Kelly] She's gonna do something.
- It was is wild.
Then cut to.